starting with this weird selector right
here with dollar sign open parentheses
quotes quotes close parentheses this is
an indication that you're using jQuery
the dollar sign parentheses quote syntax
is only used for jQuery and it grabs an
element on the page which in this case
is the class identified by this dot
super header wrapper we run the dot HTML
method on it which in this case is going
to replace the HTML of everything of the
class super header wrapper with the HTML
we see right here in this case this HTML
is going to embed a picture so when I
press ENTER we can see that we've now
changed the Udacity homepage to this
awesome picture of the Android teaching
on the Udacity platform that is an
awesome picture and just to be clear you
only made the change for this local copy
of the page not the actual website so if
you refresh the page you'll see that it
goes back to normal